what began as a family party now
described as a national tragedy
Flames tore through this home in the
densely populated gebalia refugee camp
in Northern gaza's strip
neighbors say they could hear screaming
but the fire was so intense they
couldn't help those trapped inside
I was sleeping in the living room that
looks out to my neighbors I was asleep
with my five-year-old and I heard people
screaming so I woke up
our brothers in the civil defense
arrived tried to enter the apartment but
couldn't they had no masks and no oxygen
tanks and the people burned inside and
until that moment we still didn't go
even one meter into the apartment the
dead are all believed to be of the
aburaya family they were gathering to
celebrate a birthday and welcoming home
their father who obtained a PhD overseas
but now their home is just a wreck of
charred walls and black suits
there was a large amount of fuel on
location which acted as a fire hazard
teams of firefighters quickly rushed to
the scene and the civil defense opened
an immediate investigation
the civil defense teams face great
difficulty in containing the enormous
fire a large number of fire brigade
officers and Palestinian police rushed
to the scene and had to use a lot of
equipment to put out the flames and to
prevent it from spreading to neighboring
homes and areas
those who survived the blaze have been
rushed to local hospitals Israel
maintains a blockade of Gaza but says it
will help those in need of medical
treatment
Palestinian president Mahmoud Abbas says
the victims will be remembered with the
day of national Mourning
you see it Al Jazeera gazda